[Music]
peekaboo
[Music]
no no no no no I didn't mean to startle
you my little baby
Hush little vampire don't say a word
Papa's gonna bite the head of a bird
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
nice but maybe a little more square
footage I want a lot of monsters here
[Music]
right out there oh we never go out there
ever
and then the monsters ran away and were
forced into hiding but Harry the human
found them and jumped out from under
their bed I'm scared and burned their
clothes and beat their toes and took
their candy
don't take my candy baby clothes you
don't need to be frightened I promised
your mommy I would protect you forever
my beautiful Navy
let me wipe all your poop away
those humans are nesting
so with Daddy you will stay and if a
human tries to harm you I'll simply say
because you're daddy's girl
daddy's girl
just bend the legs and push off trust me
Mouse
[Music]
look at you faster baby faster you got
it my little voodoo doll
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you